because the Broncos are for the big
ladies for the big old women of San
Antonio yeah that's what they Market I'm
talking about the woman the big big old
Bloomers in San Antonio can't you grab
it with this one and then feed it to
this one not not the corpus
Stevens
[Music]
so you guys ever been in a car and you
felt like you had the T-Rex arms because
you couldn't quite get to the seat belt
oh when you feel like this yeah you're
like yeah trying to reach for the
seatbelt so the new Ford Bronco SUV or
they're from 2021 to 2023 they're
recalling 176 000 of them oh [__] no
because they were so sought after
because drivers and front seat
passengers can have difficulty reaching
the metal portion of the belt when it's
retracted so it's like a stroll it back
and you can't you cancel that you can't
quit really I didn't think that would
qualify for a recall yeah that's what so
they're Ford is saying the customer or
always going through [__] dude some
dissatisfaction or be discouraged if
they are unable to easily access the
seat belt if it's in a stowed position
dissatisfaction and discouragement
qualifies now and they just wow they
just have to rotate but there's like
absolutely so they're saying that it
probably worked but then they forgot to
factor in the fat asses that's going to
be buying the truck or
the fat [__] can't reach
I don't want to be liable they don't
want to say it because that is a
liability they're saying that it because
of this flaw drivers are less likely to
use oh so they're like man yep well
that's on them but if they're less
likely to use it right that's not yeah
but this is only for the five-door
version that's why like they did a lot
of models or they did a lot of release
for those two years but this is 176 000
of them that's a lot though it's a
significant amount a lot that is such a
it feels like such a gray area still it
is because it the problem only occurs
when the front seats are in like a
certain position it's like saying it you
know what the AC uses too much gas so
I'm not going to turn it on and I'm
going to die of heat stroke yeah that's
so foolish right because yeah it's the
damnedest thing though they won't say
which position the seat has to be in to
to replicate this issue it's probably a
fat [__] position it's the guy leaning
all the way back like that is it a
flexibility issue is it because we're
not as flexible as we used to be or do
not even know where my where are you
guys apparently it's a fat [__] ability
yeah probably
all right think about it right like we
could do this yeah if you're [__]
you can't do this your tricep is hitting
the battery you're not just fat you're
but you're a fat [__] so you're trying
to reach around so you're also yeah yeah
you have like [__] Triple E titties
you're trying to get around and you
can't even get on get over there if
you're dude if you're a fat [__] you
can't even do this yeah but doesn't that
mean they can't do that in any car yeah
exactly especially why is it just the
Bronco because the Broncos for the big
ladies for the big old women of San
Antonio yeah that's what they Market
you know what I'm talking about can't
you go like I'm talking about the
women's the big big old Bloomers in San
Antonio can't you grab it with this one
and then feed it to this one not not the
Corpus Christi behemoths
we just keep relating Texas cities so
that's Charles Barkley's take on San
Antonio women you said that they're huge
yeah Charles Barkley's the best why did
he say that get away with any of you
because he's talking about how he
doesn't like San Antonio women when when
did they what was the context of
bringing that up at all flown over there
and he's seen it like a bunch of times
he plays the San Antonio a lot yeah I
didn't see that many big women in San
Antonio I never saw the big big old
women I didn't see more in Vegas like
the women who you have to open both
doors of Claim Jumper to let them in
it's a big doors big
doors they gotta go through the freight
area
yeah go through the kitchen dude and
when they go to Costco you got to put
them into the Docking Bay oh geez in San
Antonio's a big win in San Antonio yeah
let's just finding somewhere Charles
Barkley even brought that up he did many
times during the basketball show he has
yeah all the time but Charles Barkley
has really hot takes he's got he's got
the best hot takes that's why we watch
uh TNT tonight that's my favorite are
you sure it was Charles Barkley and it
last show on television it wasn't just a
guy that looks like no it's Charlie be
gone wannabe because the best part is
that the whole time that he's doing this
Shaq's only purpose of the show is to
laugh at everything Chuck said
um shake his head again
[Laughter]
so it does make sense now that we have
considered all these factors yeah I knew
exactly what it was you did
so do you think you really think they
would have a backlash if they had to
straight up say hey people above this
weight like you have to be this
small to enjoy the seat belt I don't
know that it's a backlash but whatever
it is they don't want to get sued yeah
damn they got it oh because it could be
a discriminatory design I don't know
that's like the um
you think they're gonna say remember the
Mario Land ride are people getting
something
it has a lower threshold for like size
yeah you can't do but you can't get it
but are most of those rides made for
kids why does your adult ass want to be
on it yeah it should they should have a
sign that just says you can't be from
San Antonio
and then a parenthesis because the women
are big things because when you go to
Legoland some of that [__] I'm like oh
man it's only for kids yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know he traveled way more
than I am yeah he's been to all the
states yep more than I have yeah who has
a better idea of the the demographics of
women over there probably Charles
Barkley definitely NBA player you know
what's something about the Ford Bronco
that you think made everyone want to get
it I have a theory what is it well it's
actually they brought it back it looks
cool but like all the old ones yeah and
people had it there's like waiting lists
for it and then uh most Broncos like at
the dealer it's like 20 20 to 50K above
sticker price which is crazy yeah it's
really like 20K above like people know
that if I ordered it if I bought and I'd
drive it off the lot I can literally
sell it tomorrow and make 50 G's on it
that's crazy yeah OJ fans that's what I
think that's your theory it made it sexy
[__] it did it
so did the Hyundai Elantra blow up after
that one True Crime Story I think it's a
cool design like I like it I mean if I
if I were to get another car I'd
probably get one too but then just the
Ford's got to step it up man they they
stay [__] up so hard
what if it turns out Dahmer drove like a
Chevy Tahoe or something do you think
stales would be up but it had to be
iconic like like this was on TV oh
that's a [__] police are chasing it I
remember exactly where I was in Fairfax
Virginia when the juice was loose that
was what they're saying
yeah man great headline all right so
good the um remember that one video of a
Dodge Challenger it was white and the
copter was trying to tail it and it got
away it just gunned it and it got the
[__] out of there they went like 100
sales went up on that thing really
because people were like car actually
got away from the helicopter I could I
could be I could be Vin Diesel that's
what people are saying did he sell dude
depart depart in the fast movie where he
like they're going down the hill and
he's like and she's like she's like
don't do it he's like aims for the
bridge and then somehow the bridge like
cable gets connected to the car and they
get swung off a cliff I'm like don't
don't say it with that face it's
plausible
I saw one clip on Instagram where Vin
Diesel he's jumping in mid-air and he
catches a car have you seen that oh what
he catches a car right here did you see
that they're they there their Feud is
done they squashed it they squash it and
they're gonna make a yeah jumping in
dude
how did they squash it that was like a
deep deep what maybe they're like if we
squash this we could both make a billion
dollars
that's a nice reason to squash it right
the last one that came out was 10 right
yeah how did it do did it do okay all
right it did great in my book man I
loved it did you but I love it
like that so you'll make 11 now they
have to because because 12 now well I
don't oil I don't want to spoil it but
now the neck now I think that they
agreed they're going to do as well the
craziest franchise let's just say
there's no way they made 10 without
already starting 11. there's no way they
made more of these than Star Wars movies
but they're better than the Star Wars
movies
last three I was like yeah they're bad
yeah
I wanted to get up and get okay I was so
pissed I was watching I was like what is
it they ruined Luke Skywalker it just
wasn't a fun movie dude they ruined him
projects himself in front of yeah dude
you think George Lucas looks at Vin
Diesel
how do you do it man
give me some of that give me some
whatever he's having teach me dude
you're gonna make 12 Movies he calls
them up he's like do you want to be
Anakin Skywalker dude am I Apprentice I
think it's pretty cool that the Star
Trek movies have gotten so good the Star
Trek movies are cool yeah because Spock
is pretty cool which ones I like the
first one was doing it when what's his
name was uh papers April yeah yeah I
like the one where he goes he screams
Khan I like that that's my favorite Star
Trek movie that one's sick the wrathicon
yeah yeah that one was tight because you
actually gave a [__] the stakes were
high majorly high it's one of the best
science fiction movies ever made that
[__] was tight yeah so glad you need the
last Skywalker I never get to talk to
people about this [__] I'm sorry uniting
on the hatred of the movie dude I said I
hated it too no I know but like he
actually knows about it you just oh I
know about it you just hate everything
you don't even watch Star Wars dude I
love Star Wars no you don't I like Rogue
one Rogue one was done
I like I like the you know
Mandalorian bro you know
Lando Calrissian
[Music]
foreign